[Music]
hey
what's up everyone um welcome to culture
binge
this is the wisecrack podcast where we
dive deep into the cultural zeitgeist to
tell you what's going on
um i am michael joins as always by the
bubba gump of the serial aisle
alec alec how are you today great great
and
serbia the judy bloom of corporate
astrology how are you doing today
i'm well thank you yeah this is good i'm
good i think
i think we're live and we weren't live
last time
so um it's always good to be live always
good to
you know have the thrill of of you know
the the failures stay in anyone who's
watching us right now we could screw up
and they're gonna see it and it could be
beautiful of course if you're listening
to this after the fact
we'll cover it all up um now we've got a
lot to talk about today it's actually
been
a genuinely busy week in culture it
seems like things are picking back up
like we're not even gonna talk about
the big boat that was stuck in the canal
that's how many good topics there are to
talk about
then we're not talking about the boat um
we're gonna get into
you know satan and what satan's up to
we'll talk about books and we'll talk
about shrimps
and cereal um and the the constant
phenomenon of milkshake ducking
first and foremost let's do some slaps
and traps um
serbie can we start with you sure so uh
what chaps last i'd say the last few
weeks have been kind of hard
i've been reflecting a lot on like
different experiences in my life and
you know when you just start to go down
this rabbit hole and you remember
all the like the shittier things that
have happened
so i'm going through that right now like
just remembering moments of like
sexism and racism and all the other isms
um and it doesn't feel great so
my mood's been a little bit low however
what has helped me is watching good
girls
on netflix um it's super fun
i love christina hendricks anything
she's in
i will watch it um so i'm really
enjoying it
if you want to watch a fun show that uh
is quite engaging check out goodgirls on
netflix
i wish i'd sponsored by netflix yeah
netflix reach out also
serbia i'm very sorry you're going
through that you should however
when you think of these experiences make
a list of anyone who ever hurt you
then we can put that on the patreon and
wisecrack patrons then
will form an assassin squad it's a new
thing we're working on and they will
take care of it so
join our patreon especially if you have
assassin-based skills
um everything's cool we pay via dark web
money
um alec slap some chats for you
uh slaps is i got a vaccine appointment
i don't believe it's real
take it away from me uh i think they're
gonna show up and be like
you thought you were eligible you're not
over 30 i'm over 30 but anyway
um so that's cool and then you know if
you ask them
and you do it right the microchips that
go into you can actually use like a
cyborg from dc situation so i'm going to
be like extra smart
i'm going to have some like cool
abilities after the fact um
and what chaps is i don't know anything
about it
except white boy summer i don't know
what it is but i hate it so much
you didn't order your official white boy
summer hoodie in like the legit
third reich font that he picked i did
not know that
he did that this is chet hanks for
anyone who knows a weird son of time
means chet hayes the hip-hop artist who
happens to be related to tom hanks
he got there by himself yeah um what did
you know i saw this on the website
twitter.com today
um a flat tummy t influencer did a
really
important post and let me know that um
the vaccine's technically not fda
approved so i'm rethinking
a lot of things i guess emergency
authority authorization is not
approval so just like be careful what
you're putting in your body
before you two bands that's a joke yeah
it's definitely a joke
get all the vaccines i would get four
doses if i could i would
get them all once do you know which one
you're getting uh moderna
so i'm gonna create like a weird gang
war with other like johnson johnson
people you're dead to me
wow yeah that's really exciting friend
from
um work so she has a similar uh immune
system
as me like we're allergic to everything
um
and so she got pfizer on monday and
she's been vomiting
since she's got this on dose one yeah
damn most people get all froggy a dose
too but
dose one's sick that's a bummer yeah
that's why
but you know what i'd rather be docic
than
to be that type of sick um
covet sick yes well that's very exciting
um if you're in new york that's great i
would just say
we're not a public health podcast but if
you can like if you're eligible where
you live
could we just say that we think it's
good if you get a vaccine can we all
agree on that is that cool
yeah if you're eligible yeah because
some of us aren't eligible
some of us are 50 years old and actually
no i'm 20 years old and really healthy
so i'm last in line
um you know me and other guys on the
ucla college swim team
i have such good health that we're last
um now before we get into the topics
just a reminder
it'll be meaningful to us if you
subscribe to this podcast so even if you
are or someone that likes to watch the
stream on youtube and be a part of the
live experience which i think is rad
that's what i want to do too
go subscribe on itunes or spotify or
stitcher
those are the three that i'm aware of
and if you do that
give us five stars or five thumbs up or
five whatever
they have and then leave a review
and if you leave something fun in the
review we'll read it
um we've encouraged you before to tell
us you know what cocktail we'd be
what work of classic literature what
type of produce you can come up with
something but just tell us what we would
be in a certain category
and we might talk about this again a
little bit later but do that it'd be
meaningful to us
speaking of things that are meaningful
to us alec what's up with satan this
week
oh so you know satan's having a great
week uh i don't know if you
know about satan but uh he was like the
right hand to god
was pissed about it was like actually
i'm in charge um and then come on this
is this is easter week alex this is
the bit's going too far i'm offended
uh little nos x old town road guy put
out a song called montero call me by
your name
i think old timer is better that's fine
we're not here to talk about whether or
not you like the song
we're here to talk about the uh i
the satanic panic that it caused i
thought you know uh in 2021 we were we
were done i thought
you know i was growing up there was
harry potter is satanic
there was dungeon and dragon dragons
satanic heavy metal
people are going to start drinking the
the blood of children um and i thought
we were done with that but apparently
we're not uh will not sex so for context
this video
starts with the artist uh kind of like
an imagination land where desires can't
be suppressed it's very kind of adam and
eve there's a serpent around a tree
he goes maybe up to heaven but then gets
cast down to hell
and bottoms for satan which is cool um
people are not happy about it uh here's
from a complex article
uh also talking about wap which i
believe stands for uh wet ass b-word
uh uh both [ __ ] and montero were all so
crazy
was gonna say it everyone i thought he
was gonna say it i got really excited
what
kind of podcast now this is from complex
uh both
uh wap and montero were also criticized
on the grounds that they corrupted
children last night
joyner lucas saluted nasa x for the
video
quote creating viral moments making
people talk and creating content he
already
knew he was going to react to and quote
he called it a formula guaranteed to
work but then tweeted a sentiment that
essentially stayed a little
hot not sex should be cognizant of kids
in his creative process because children
liked old town road and subscribed to
him on youtube not sex succinctly
replied i literally sing about lean
uh that's uh codeine infused drink for
people unaware
uh lean and adultery in old town road
you decide to let your children listen
blame yourself uh i really like golden
osx just
uh dunking on people i think more than
his music that's
that's kind of what i i like most about
him yeah uh he did some
elite posting this week just elite level
posting
we're gonna get into something sorry um
this is later in that complex article
there were several politicians who used
wap as low-hanging fruit to portray
themselves as morally upright figures
last election season
just a couple days after montero nossex
announced satan sneakers a limited
edition rendering
of the air max 97s with reference to the
bible verse
luke 10 18 which says he replied i saw
satan fall like lightning from heaven
south dakota governor christie noem came
out against the shoes on twitter
blustering our kids are being told
that this kind of product is not only
okay it's exclusive
but you know what's more exclusive the
god-given eternal soul
uh was that what the governor actually
said or is that you adding a riff on the
end
wow no that's that's what uh an actual
politician said
uh things uh escalated
in a variety of ways uh the kent state
gun girl who
got famous for carrying around guns was
mad uh at which point lil nassak
threatened
to [ __ ] her dad um it was a whole thing
um but yeah i mean first things first uh
what do you all think
i think there's an a significant amount
of drama
about shoes and a song when um
i don't really see the big deal like
it's just it's just a pair of shoes and
it's just a song
yeah yeah like the thing too is
the one bummer is no one's really
talking about the song
and if it's good or not um it's more
about this viral moment which is fine i
get that like that's a part of it
but yeah just like who cares um when i
was a kid
well let me age myself here i mean like
marilyn manson did tons of crazy [ __ ]
and was on mtv
all the time and was a huge part of
culture like tons of
music that happened to be created by
people that don't look like little nas x
um in the 90s dealt with like satanic
and dark and occult themes
so it's like whatever that's always been
a part of culture and even like
the medieval and renaissance eras there
was art that represented this type of
stuff so it's not like the dude invented
satan
um and in the shoes as well it's like
sure some company made some like special
shoes for the video like who
cares it's kind of fun and then the
whole thing around like
what about kids like are you telling me
that all
of of human culture all of art music
literature should constrain itself
because of the potential that a
precocious 14 year old
is going to read or listen to it like
that's just going to happen and if
you're a parent and you care about this
stuff
then i guess i don't know like lock your
kid in a closet without its ipad
also if some 14 year old is like when i
grow up i want to [ __ ] satan like
i what's the i see no harm in that you
know like you're not going to
it's not like my kid says like i want to
grow up in like [ __ ] tom brady and i'm
like okay
tom brady is a person who exists maybe
you're gonna have sex with tom brady one
day
you're not going to have sex with satan
and then maybe that's a conversation you
have with your kid like what does that
mean
you desire darkness and transgression
what does that say about
your psychology what are you
transgressing against let's get to the
bottom of that
is this really the best demon to want to
[ __ ] like what about baphomet what about
mammon like there are other demons out
there all these demons i bet
he doesn't know the names of demons um
that's a good thing by the way serbia i
think you're because you're a
well-adjusted person you can't just list
off demons like their pokemon cards
there there is a component i think
you're touching on this which is
like i think it's very funny but at the
same time i feel like i'm being conned
into caring
um because i mean marilyn manson
in the 90s his business model as a
musician was to like offend
conservative evangelical christians who
would like protest his concerts and like
he would cash in because angsty 14 year
olds could be like i'm deep and dark
because i like things that look like the
devil
um but i mean like
in a weird way this is all coming down
to like is this just
i mean not that the whole video and
everything about it is trying to sell
shoes
but in a weird way it comes down to that
like
you know conservatives are mad at him
for like promoting satan or whatever and
that's
it's almost like like i think these
people believe these things but
like the same people who are all about
like free speech are like oh but not
about like gay sex stuff and satan like
so you know i think
they are being hypocrites but in a way
that they don't care about because it's
all about like the projection
of this thing and on the other side like
on the left it's like the projection of
like depending on
x and needing to say like oh what he's
doing is like super cool and important
and again like i'm not really here to
break apart like the artistic message of
it yeah
but you know when you're selling
thousand dollar satan shoes
which you know if your sneaker hadn't
wanna spend thousand dollars there's a
little bit of human blood in them
allegedly
uh i don't know is little nos x dunking
on caitlyn bennett and her poo poo pants
like just a way to sell sneakers and
more albums and at that point should we
care
are we complicit for karen yeah well you
know one thing too we should note is
that when he put the video out he posted
on his twitter like a note to himself
that was to his child self basically
saying like hey
you're confused you feel bad about like
your desires your sexuality whatever
you shouldn't that's awesome you're
beautiful and that [ __ ] rules yeah
and that's
so important for like young people to
see that message and i think that's
something like and we brought in marilyn
manson let's just make it clear too
will not ex seems like a cool guy
marilyn manson total piece of [ __ ] we're
not saying that he's good because
marilyn manson's message wasn't like
affirming like queer kids that felt
alienated so i think the fact that
little nazix is doing that
is is just objectively good and cool and
a great part of this
um maryland would do things like war is
bad and like your politicians are lying
to you
i mean i'm not defending rape yeah no no
he's a bad man
yeah but he said in like a vapid
meaningless way um
also did you guys know that marilyn
manson is actually paul from the wonder
years but grown up
google it not true that's what people
said when i was young
also by saying the wonder years most of
you just said what is that now you're
going to look it up you're going to see
what year it came out you're going to
say is michael 50
but um what you were just saying alec
reminded me too of there's one of my
favorite lines from um
soren kierkegaard philosophy bro from
denmark uh
he talks about this this thing in his
culture he's like people used to to
relate to ideas with thought and passion
now everything is advertising and
publicity and i do think that is my
cynical take on this whole thing that
like there's a good message attached to
about how much of the roll out of the
song and video
is about an attempt at art and how much
about it
is just advertising in publicity
and riling up you know social media fuel
or social media energy
without an artistic product at the
center of it and maybe me saying product
was indicative of the problem here
um that has something to say and i don't
know but i just think that's
me and i think that a question both can
be true right like yeah well not sex
is certainly doing like art like artists
making artistic choices standing for
certain things putting certain things in
his art but also i think he'd be like
but also i know this is going to create
a shitstorm if i like
twerk on the devil so i'm gonna do that
and sometimes like provocation
is the point and that's fine but
there's there's a tension there that i
think is interesting yeah i'm
always really frustrated when something
will come out and
you have all of these people who say
things like what about kids and this is
bad for children and what are we
teaching our kids
you're teaching your kids what you want
to teach them
so it's a parent's responsibility if
your kid is exposed to something you
don't want
them exposed to then you need to be the
one to have a conversation with your
child
that's what my mom did with me when like
marilyn manson was on mtv
she'd be like let's discuss this let's
talk about what he's wearing let's talk
about what he's saying
how do you feel do you have any
questions she wouldn't just assume
oh great she's going to join a satanic
cult now because she was exposed to
marilyn manson
yeah and i think there's like this big
burden that's placed on like
people other than a family unit a family
union yeah
it's also funny like a lot of
you know there was this panic in the 90s
about music there's always been a panic
about corrupting
things i think we lose sight of the like
historical nature but
in the moment that like tipper gore was
freaking out about like rap music
like i was in the car on the radio
listening to afternoon delight which is
about [ __ ]
during the afternoon and like on one end
it's just like kids don't
i mean i think like a kid seeing little
nazak's dancing on the devil
probably doesn't understand most the
context in the same way i didn't
understand afternoon delight was about
[ __ ]
in the same way that like a parent of
mine got really upset that i was
listening to the band orgy i
literally did not know what the word
orgy meant until he got mad about it
um and so it's all stupid
yeah um yeah i mean i just think it did
yeah i think you're right and i think
that
if it was true that music was going to
ruin the youth it would have happened
because
every generation has something like this
we have to remember that like
like they wouldn't show elvis dancing on
tv
because it was too sexual and
provocative and society didn't collapse
in the late 50s early 60s the same thing
happened with like the hippie era
and all the woodstock people grew up to
become like investment bankers
so they're and who like live in
connecticut no offense shouts to
connecticut
but like yeah i know i just said it
because you know some people that are
part of the wisecrack team have have
connecticut roots
um but yeah i don't know it just this
keeps happening
it's kind of dumb and i think we're at a
point where
i would have hoped that like the culture
wars would have mellowed out and they've
just gotten worse and more stratified
but whatever you know because the people
that are
mad at will nas x probably listen to
really bad music
um you know like they probably are not
experiencing like cool art like they're
going on
they're going on pure flicks they're
listening to like cassette tapes of amy
grant from nike are they listening
to chat hanks no chet hayes is for the
people but
um i've never listened to a chet hey
song and i won't
because i want to like let myself
believe um
that it's good but we're not talking
about white boy summer right now
so i don't want to ruin the little
nondex conversation and dilute it with
chet hayes but i don't know and the
thing too is like this is all going to
blow over in two days so i think the
interesting thing will be
um in general maybe this is me getting
off topic a little bit
i'm just curious to see what happens
with little nazaks as a musician right
he had this huge song old town road
his next single was called panini and
while i love
a heated pressed sandwich that one
didn't really do numbers
i'm curious to see what this one does
curious to see if this dude has
something to say
he's very young pretty creative he's
down with trying weird [ __ ]
so i think if anything like it'll be
cool to see what this guy does next and
he's handling it very well all things
considered
um by trolling his critics and i think
being confident
that he has something to say and has
every right to say it which i think is
great
yeah so yeah um
serbia are you going to immediately get
off this podcast and blast lil nas x
during your next work meeting
yeah i've never heard anything he's um
done so i'm gonna check it out charlie i
feel like we've heard
old town road but maybe you haven't and
it's
it's catchy familiar is it sort of like
a country song as well
yeah and they put and they put billy ray
cyrus in it to put it on the country
charts because people are like this
isn't country music it's not quite
being racist also
country music is so crazy because let me
say this so if there's any country heads
you listen to this i really like a lot
of like
more traditional country and by that i
mean like good songwriting
and i don't mean like old crazy white
guys on my favorite country artist is
margo price who's like a badass
cool um edgy feminist woman but
we i was watching the grammys and they
did all the country performances
all it is is pop music sung by
mostly white people who just aren't that
good at singing and couldn't sing
like r b music well like the song
structure
is just pop music there's nothing about
it that makes it discernibly country
and then sometimes they even do like
cadences that are cripped from like rap
and r b music
so it's sort of just like are you just
afraid to make pop or r b
music so you say it's country and
there's like a steel guitar
like twang every six bars i don't know
not for me
uh all right there it is shout out in
the comments
um and everyone watch that video
let us know what you think very curious
to talk with you about satan
um now satan we know of because of the
bible
the bible is a book books have been
known
to to change lives serbia i feel like
you wanted to take some time
to get us back to the importance of
literature
and its life-changing impact am i wrong
and if no
the floor is yours that was a really
slick transition i appreciate it that's
what i do
um so i've been thinking a lot about
books because
uh so as i mentioned earlier i've been
thinking a lot about my life and
growing up i often felt like an outsider
um i grew up in an area where there
weren't a lot of people that looked like
me or had a similar culture
um like for example when i would say i
was
i'm indian people would ask what tribe
i'm from um
and on top of that i'm also i was also
just really outspoken
as a kid i had an opinion about
everything and i wanted to share it with
everyone
so i always felt like i didn't quite fit
in um
i looked different i sounded different
and i wasn't
better or worse than anyone i just was
different so
to escape i read a lot and i
would develop really strong attachments
to
um the characters in books and i would
laugh and cry and i would feel
everything so strongly and i still do
even now if a character dies in a book
i'll
feel like i'm in mourning if something
great happens then i'll want to
celebrate
um and i think a lot of my personality
developed as a result of the books that
i read
as a kid and i wear my heart on my
sleeve and i think it's in large part
to literature and um
recently beverly cleary died and for
those of you who don't know
she was a novelist who created the
wonderful character
ramona quimby um she wrote several
children's books
but the series that she's perhaps best
known for is the one about
ramona and she's young i think she's
about like eight or nine
um and it's about her life and some of
these books are called beezus and ramona
ramona the pest and ramona the brave
and i love these books i think my
um my mom bought me the first one
and she was like you would really like
this and i think i was about six or
seven
and i just loved it ramona is smart
and she's quirky and weird and outspoken
she's annoying
she feels everything so passionately and
deeply and she's so
so brave and i learned a lot
from her as a young girl and i've been
reading a lot of articles about beverly
cleary
um and about ramona and
this excerpt from alison hope's article
perfectly captures my feelings she
writes ramona is there for all of us
pets
who speak up in meetings even when the
men interrupt to talk over us
for us pests who show up unabashedly
sporting our soccer shirts and our short
hair and our big personalities
and our we don't take crap from anyone
attitude
thanks to beverly cleary ramona quimby
will still be there
to fuel the spirits of future female
presidents and ceos
rock stars and scientists she'll keep
guiding us with that little voice
cleary helped create in our psyches
telling us we can do it
and there's so much power in words in
the literature
and it shapes our perspectives and it
can help determine how we react to the
world around us
and other books that have helped me
are the boxcar children um
i learned about caring for the people
you love um
harry potter i learned to be brave uh
anne of green gables
um i learned about awkwardness social
awkwardness and it's okay to not be the
prettiest
person in the room um and intelligence
is beautiful
i learned about having the courage to
try
from the phantom toll booth and from
hatchet
i learned that sometimes you're alone
and afraid and angry and the only person
you can count on
is yourself and i feel like there are
times throughout my life when i will
revisit books to remind myself of these
lessons
um for example i've been going through
like really challenging things at work
recently and
i go back to hatchet because at the end
of the day
it's it's me like i have to be the one
to figure out
an action plan i have to be the one
who's solution focused
um so i know like it's like a book on
the surface
and it's a children's book nonetheless
but still there are lessons to be
learned so i'm curious what books
you have or what authors you followed
throughout your lives that have
meant something to you and have impacted
your
careers or your perspectives or shaped
your personalities
do it alec oh okay um
i feel like especially in the fiction
department
probably very outraged by serbia but
same
um one book that i have gone back to and
read a few times
uh is life on the mississippi by mark
twain
i read a long time ago i wasn't always
into reading as a kid like i
read a few books but i think there was
like a particular moment when i was like
16 or 17 where i just started reading a
ton
and i think i read it like in that
two-year span but anyway
um it's a it's semi-fictional about mark
twain's
experience as a riverboat captain on the
mississippi river
um and what i found was really
interesting and i think kind of like
open new doors for me like as a reader
and as a person is like
on paper it's the most boring thing ever
right like do i want to read
like a 600 page book or 400 page book on
a guy
dr like floating a boat up and down a
river like no but like it's all the sort
of
tangents and adventures it goes on you
know like as he
meets people as he goes on shore as he
hears stories from other people
um and just this kind of like incredible
snapshot i think of
you know american life at that time
um and i think it's really given me
i think better perspective on sort of
like learning
and sort of appreciate the world around
you and even sort of like
his love of the mississippi river which
is a weird thing to love
in prior to this you're like oh like i
get it and i think that kind of informs
um how i think about a lot of things i
could also probably name a bunch of boss
people
i don't think philosophy books are
boring uh it's actually this book called
uh on the matter of boston stop it
stop this guy michael johnny
um no those are good and also too serbia
just incredible list you had there um
i think everyone should just hopefully
when you're if you're listening
rewind it like hit that button that goes
back 30 seconds like
four to five times and then just write
down everything serbia said um
i am you know demographically alec we're
just showing
our our uh homogeneity here because
mark twain was also important to me as
a young person but i think for me like
the thing i liked about mark twain and
you know like the
the the greatest hits like uh sawyer and
finn
are that like he gets at the idea that
it's okay to maybe be like a little bit
alienated weird out of it curious
reckless
in a way that makes you feel at odds
with your family your classmates or your
friends
but that's okay um and i know that was
something i really connected with
i think i kind of had my first moment
where books
helped me a lot or like changed my life
in my
college years um because not to be like
too real but like
service did some real stuff so i'm
allowed to do as well um
i i didn't grow up in an environment
where things like like mental health
were spoken about
openly or where that was even like a
thing so i think
for years and years i was like suffering
from different forms of like anxiety and
depression but just didn't know what
that was and just felt like bad about
myself or like i was weird or there was
something wrong with me
and there were some books i read um in
like my college years and right after
college really helped me a lot one was a
novel by an
author named um benjamin kunkel who
mostly just writes about like marxist
uh economics now but was his first book
was a novel called
um indecision which i don't know just i
liked a lot and had a character who was
a little neurotic and was reading
philosophy and didn't know what to do
with his life
um also had a sexual fixation on his
sister which i did not relate to
but that was in the book as well um but
something that made me like
i don't know feel a little like seen and
felt like it was okay
and that we can be in a weird spot not
know what's going on with our life and
then there was a series of books that i
read
right after college um by an author
named lars iyer who i i like a lot
you should all read his books but his
first three books are a trilogy
called the spurious trilogy it's
spurious dogma and exodus
and they're three short books they're
kind of like beckett vibes
that are two uh functional alcoholic
philosophers
um at the odds of british culture trying
to find meaning in the world
um and and failing and kind of like
dealing with the impending doom of
reality while everyone around them
acts like everything's okay and i found
those like comforting so i think for me
like
books where characters have been like
depressed
or anxious or have even been like
dealing with apocalyptic themes have
made me feel comforted
because it's a reminder that like that's
real people can feel those things
um and i will just say alex didn't want
to talk about philosophy
i will say there's a philosophy book
that did change my life a lot
by a philosopher named adrian johnston
if you like philosophy i think he's one
of the most important like
currently working writing philosophers
and he has this book called
jesus ontology now you hear that and
you're like
yeah you're like oh a book about slav
voyage by another white guy that
probably has a beard i don't think he
has a beard
but it's not i think it was named that
for marketing stuff it's mostly about
his own [ __ ] but i remember reading it
on a train ride and things clicking
like a moment where a lot of
philosophical ideas clicked and it gave
me a lot of focus
and it's what got me to the point where
i wrote like my dissertation and
eventually my book
um and i got very lucky in that this is
a person i eventually got to know and
was very
kind to me which is always always rips
but
that was important and i would be lying
if i didn't say that it didn't change my
life
oh it feels like in some so
what you said about having anxiety and
depression so i also
have anxiety and depression and i slip
in and out
in and out of them throughout my life
since i was young
and it almost feels like literature is
a form of therapy because i find myself
drawn to characters who are going
through similar things
and seeing how they move through
move through these challenges or handle
certain
events i i feel like i learn from that
even if it's not just a book
like i mean this is like super lame but
like
um so i've mentioned on the podcast
before i broke my boyfriend and i broke
up
last year um and
watching shit's creek i don't want to
like give away anything
but there's a storyline in shit's creek
that feels
very some not very similar but it it
there's like um there are some
similarities
and watching it unfold i remember just
sobbing and was like oh gosh i wasn't
prepared for this
my boyfriend and i just broke up a month
ago um
but seeing how that character moved
forward with that and then seeing how
another character
how um there could have been a similar
situation but they worked it out i think
seeing those two things happen it it
helped me
cope with what i was going through so in
a lot of ways
books are the cheapest form of therapy
um
and it's nice to hear that that uh burns
you've also had
uh experiences where you've sort of
thought you were weird or different and
then
you found some sort of escape or help in
books
yeah it was good until i started working
at a company where i had a boss whose
name is alec that just messaged me every
day and says you're weird you're
different
um at a constant clip but no you're
absolutely right and do you think
there's something like therapeutic about
literature this has been you know
written about by lots of folks much
smarter than i but
i think there is something like even
about the mechanism of
you know encountering a book seeing
yourself and other characters
and getting engaged in that process of
like experiencing an empathy for
characters or feeling even seen by
characters in a book i think is really
important i think that
and i to be clear i love tv and movies
this is not a dis on tv and movies i'm
not one of those guys but
there is something active about reading
that i think often we don't have when
we're watching moving images that can
often have more of a pacifying
experience which is fine
um and i just don't think you can
replicate that the the active experience
of reading i think it does something to
your brain
that a lot of other methods of culture
consumption do not
perfect yeah um any final thoughts on
the book thing
let us know what books uh you've read
please do um i will say the last two
novels i read i liked a lot one was uh
fake accounts by lauren oiler which i
mentioned i think a few episodes ago and
someone wrote and said they read it and
liked it
and i'm reading this book right now the
life of the mind by christine smallwood
that i'm liking a lot as well
that's about kind of like a a depressed
failing academic person so
i don't really don't relate to that one
but um it seems cool
throw your books in the chat instead of
saying weird things like legalize crack
have no idea
what that has to do with this
conversation a lot of weird stuff
happening
well i mean i would say the legalization
of crack
would probably be an overall beneficial
thing to society not in that people
could do crack but just that crack
wouldn't be pleased in such a
oh yeah this wasn't a statement about
drug legalization it just seemed
like a lot of weird things happening in
the chat right now uh
well hey stay weird chad and i love them
yeah also i'm gonna say this now so that
no one calls us out for this later
i just i didn't do a slap in a chat
today i i
set you both up and then i just kept it
moving and i just realized that
so i just want to say that so no one
writes us and says something like wow
burns is losing his [ __ ] mind he
didn't even do
a slap in a chap i just want everyone to
know that um
that's all um if i had to say what they
were i don't know it probably would have
been that
um i'm enjoying leaving dumb movies on
in the background sometimes when i
when i'm working at home and it's just
too quiet and weird i find that fun
my chaps it's very hot where i live but
whatever also yeah have fun in the chat
everyone
um final topic of the day we'll get to
this quickly and i know we gotta
wrap up soon because our friend serbi
has to run to an important business
meeting she has to get to via private
jet
i'm not going to say it involves mark
cuban but it involves mark cuban
um so if you were on the internet in the
past week
in any capacity there's two words that
mean something to you
and these words are shrimp guy um
i assume when i say shrimp guy alec and
serbi these words
mean something to you fair yes
okay and i assume they mean something
not good they they might have at one
point
brought joy to your heart they might
have seemed like they were introducing
some wonder into the world
but they quickly turned on you and now
when we hear the word shrimp guy most of
us think
hard pass so we'll get into the shrimp
guy saga um for anyone who didn't
uh track with this and if you didn't
that's amazing like if you don't know
what trump guy is i'm envious of you
um there's a few articles there's one um
on vox that we're gonna link to in the
description that could catch you up on
all this but here's the the tl dr
a guy named jensen carp who is a retired
white rapper
a quote unquote comedian and podcaster
and the husband of danielle fischell who
played topanga on boymy's world
wow there's a lot of layers to this
guy's life tweeted
about a week ago pictures of
what were supposedly shrimp tails he
found in
cinnamon toast crunch that he purchased
from costco
and like an angry suburban white man
started tweeting about it
and then started tweeting at general
mills
eventually was posting direct messages
he had between
himself and general mills social media
person
he treated them very kindly oh wait no
he was a total
[ __ ] um now for the first if i found
shrimp in my
cereal as a avid serial eater i i would
i would not be nice about it you used to
but your assumption here
is that someone actually found shrimp in
their cereal and didn't just plan
something to get attention
but we'll get to that um so for the
first like half day
it's a fun online saga his follow count
goes up
retweets out the wazoo everyone follows
the saga
of shrimp guy then people realize oh my
god this guy's married to topanga
even more people get involved this is
fun the internet's great isn't this
great
and then people start sharing some
stories
um and there's a few levels here so
first people started coming out and
saying
you know what i actually used to work
with this guy uh and he sucks
he was various levels of abusive
mean racist not cool to work for and
this is someone he was a producer on
the tbs rap battle show drop the mic
um and you can find these threads online
one is by a comedian writer
brittany nichols who shared some
thoughts about what it was like to work
for him
not good so that starts coming out so
it's like oh maybe this guy
this guy sucks a little bit then it
starts coming out that he's stolen
multiple ideas including um the podcast
that's on the main picture on his
twitter it's a podcast about cameo
stole the podcast idea the graphics and
he stole a bunch of other things over
the years so if you just get into this
um
jack allison has written about this
online before
this is a guy who's notorious for
stealing ideas
which is a very bad look so that sucks
then most damningly
multiple women who work in comedy and
television in los angeles
have accused him of various levels of
harassment emotional abuse verbal abuse
to the level of him telling um you know
a woman he was dating
that she should kill herself and you
know
a lot of people came out with these
stories um
so it got very dark very quick
and i will say like i hate to pull this
but you know
like i think for folks that are based in
los
angeles and are adjacent to the
industries that this guy works in
it's long been like an open secret that
like he sucks um
and is a bad dude and not cool at all
and especially anyone that like
rises to fame by being a white rapper
who then immediately abandons the genre
of like rap music
to try to transition into like a
marketing and comedy career i don't
[ __ ] trust you
um but so this you know this kind of
was was really peak milkshake ducking if
you're not aware of that term this is
the phenomenon by which
something happens online that everyone
gets excited about it sparks wonder and
joy
and soon we learn that the thing we
liked was actually bad so you know
anytime
someone goes viral and we find out that
they had a tweet from like three years
ago that was like actually i think 911
in the holocaust were good
and we're like oh no um alec go ahead
it's just based off of a satirical tweet
that's like introducing the latest
sensation milkshake tongue
we're sorry to inform you that meg shake
talk is racist yes a milkshake duck
is racist um and i saw one tweet today
or last night
where someone just pointed out that like
wow this guy really blew up his whole
life for 18
hours of viral attention um
so and i do think like the whole
milkshake ducking phenomenon this one to
me which is very
it was very fast the the cycle happened
in like 24 hours
um and i will say this i one million
percent believe
that this was [ __ ] that this person
did not find trim tails in their cereal
and that somehow this was a ploy to get
attention on the internet because by all
accounts this person
is is very bad now i'll read one quote
this is from the vox article
and and this quote is especially
disturbing considering
um a few of the women um and then these
these women all did public twitter
threads about this you can find them
it's their stories to tell um one of
these women said in particular
that he gaslit her in really horrible
ways you know so sort of like telling
her feelings and her ideas were wrong
then he said this when asked by vox he
said this is what he said about general
mills cereal
all you have to do is say this is such a
bummer we're going to look into it we're
going to recall the ones from your
costco like it's such an easy pr
thing to do but instead they wanted to
basically gaslight me
so this [ __ ] is accusing a
serial company of
gaslighting and the term that has some
pretty serious cultural connotation
and he's using that to describe um a
serial company
not responding to his claims so that's
that's that's the shrimp guy saga
what do you guys think about this one
hate him so much
i hate him so so [ __ ] much any guy
anybody not even a guy any person who
gaslights
and treats people like this i [ __ ]
hate you
yeah that's yeah
uh i do on a separate note like it's
always interesting when
there's a person and then if you talk to
anyone from la they're just like oh i
know that person's piece of [ __ ]
but like only people it's just la knows
that everyone
who's a piece of [ __ ] the the town talks
a lot i guess
it talks a lot but then there's this
weird culture of be careful what you say
if you want to work
and the the same um woman who
i think is you know performer writer who
went on the twitter thread where she
talked about his gaslighting you know he
said to this woman and another woman
and he said to one woman i guess after a
weird three-way which is a weird time to
ever say something like this
you know keep your mouth shut if you
ever want to work in this town again
and that's something like people say in
movies but people
really say [ __ ] like that and people
will say like oh we know this person's
bad
but don't say anything if you want to
work it's like not to be like real
whatever here but like it's not like the
people just knew that harvey weinstein
was a piece of [ __ ] last year
people knew that for decades um but
people wanted to get movies made and the
same thing with his jensen carp dude and
this is someone who's like
biggest credit was like the executive
producer
on a show on tbs about rapping that
nobody watched
but even that person at that level had
enough perceived power
to kind of bully people into going with
what he wanted to do so they could get
jobs
so it really sucks and i will say it's
like brave of people to then
publicly talk about this person is a
piece of [ __ ] and i wish more people
would do that not to put pressure on
them because whatever but like
we let a lot of people get away with
stuff and this guy took
what could have been a fun day on
twitter and ruined it
yeah uh yeah serbi do you i know that um
i think tapanga has been silent
it's a weird one because i don't want to
i guess it's not her fault that her
husband sucks but it's also like
everyone knows he sucks so like
do better topanga you've got a lot of
options in buenos aires
the victim maybe i know she's just
waiting to get out
you know i hope she does because i'm
sure danielle fishel seems like a nice
person
her performance as topanga was
informative for a lot of people
uh and this guy just sucks so bad i hope
that i hope that she leaves him i hope
that
no one wants to work with him ever again
um and i hope that he ends up having to
work at general mills
sorting the serial off the conveyor belt
until he collapses in the factory and
has never heard from again
was that too much not really i don't
think it was
strong enough um i can we talk for a
second about how good cinnamon toast
crunch is
yeah let's end on it we can end on a
positive note and do that unless alex do
you want to say
no i was gonna say toast crunch like
i've been getting like the
the dumb organic version not because i'm
like i
think that organic food is real or
healthier for you just like
seems more adult of me and any brand
of that genre of cereal slaps slap so
hard
i found notions there's a bagel place
that i
order bagels from if you're in los
angeles look up gross
bagels on instagram it's these two dudes
they make bagels and deliver them to
your house
um they rule but they had a special
bagel for a couple weeks that was a
cinnamon toast crunch
bagel and it like had all those flavors
on it and would get delivered fresh oh
my god
um i haven't had the cereal in a while
but the bagel flavor was incredible
i wish they'd make a gluten-free version
of it so i could eat it again
i don't think general mills doesn't make
gluten-free stuff
i don't know last i checked it wasn't
gluten-free cheerios are gluten-free now
yeah rice krispies i think oh can i say
this as well the thing i'm really
looking forward to is when it comes out
this is all fake i hope they sue
the [ __ ] out of this guy and also the
fact that you don't think about that
that you don't think to yourself
i'm gonna start this twitter thing and
i'm just like some dude
this is one of the biggest food
companies in the country can you imagine
how many millions of dollars a week go
to their legal team
and you're going to come at them and not
that that's like good corporations are
bad et cetera et cetera but
in this case i want to see the
corporation just just
just take to ruin his life i agree
not daniel fascilla we want her to get
good money in the divorce settlement and
then
his life to be ruined yeah so that's
that guy um you know you let us know if
there's a other notable
milkshake duck people that you're
interested in um and if there's cereals
you like and the most important thing
here is like you know let's just make
twitter weird again and make it fun and
not about these weird pr ploys that
show the people are terrible also it
shows how much people are obsessed with
attention that when they know their
pieces of [ __ ] they're willing to put
themselves out there like that just
crazy i'm afraid to say things and i'm a
relatively good person
um so let's let's start taking the train
into the station here um
sherby's survey's gotta go so we'll
quickly hit this up um by serbia we'll
see you soon alec and i will get the
train all the way into the station
um choo choo so we won't do a full-on um
voicemail mail bag this time but what we
do want to do
we've said we want you to um and i will
say the thing in a second
we we said um we want you to review the
podcast
so we're going to look at a review but
of course for future weeks
call us email us we want to hear about
your thoughts on little nausea and satan
tell us what books are meaningful to you
and what are your thoughts on shrimp guy
and the milkshake duck phenomenon in
general you can call us at 213-534-8807
that is 213-534-8807
i just realized that's one of the only
numbers i have memorized now and if i
end up getting arrested
there's going to be a message from me on
the wisecrack yeah
please build me arrested and um can you
google a lawyer for me
i honestly this is my one call yeah
it'll be like uh burns isn't hosting
this week we haven't heard from let's
check the voicemails it's like been here
for five weeks please help
um but you can call that number or email
us at culturebindingwisecrack.com
um please do those things we love to
read your emails and listen your
voicemails
as always even if we don't get to all of
them we read all of them we like all of
them unless they're mean
but like you wouldn't expect us to like
it if it was mean but almost no one
writes mean stuff because you all rule
um and but for the time being we have
a review i think on itunes of the
podcast
um i think alec is going to read for us
oh i'm going to read it oh jeez oh geez
oh i can do it too
no no i'll do it then it's fine it's
fine um wow alex someone asked you to
to to do something you just just
i'm doing it right now okay so this is
from tomcat choirmaster
um the the review is titled love and
happiness tomcat says wisecrack's
culture binge podcast changed my life
forever and it could change yours
too after just three episodes i joined a
crossfit gym found god and learned to
read old slavonic
after a whole season i started receiving
acceptance letters from graduate schools
i hadn't even applied to
the mayor gave me the key to the city
because of culture binge i found love in
a lonely world establish an enduring
inner peace and achieved
fully realized selfhood if you're
looking for the keys to the kingdom
everlasting youth and eternal joy well
then look no further friend thank you
wisecrack crew
p.s if and this is what we really really
love to see
if the culture binge crew were criterion
films
michael would be with nail and i love it
serbia would be rushmore
wow alec and this is great would be the
discrete charm of the bourgeoisie
haven't seen it want to watch it now um
all of those are great films
with non-eyes about two british drunks
wandering the countryside trying to find
meaning in a lonely world
it's actually the books that i mentioned
earlier that are meaningful to me
reviewers said they were like with now
for eye and i um serbie
second is rushmore second wes anderson
film
kind of cool quirky smart fun it's about
a child competing for the romantic
interest of
a teacher with bill murray most
definitely yeah
and everyone knows that serbia has
competed for romantic partners with bill
murray
multiple times she's not here so we can
talk about it now bill murray is serving
his nemesis
and the discrete charm of the
bourgeoisie i'm forgetting the
director's name right now but he's a
spanish director
made a lot of films in france and this
is kind of like absurdist
take on the like vapid nature of
bourgeois life
in the 70s and it's really weird and fun
it is
i think you can stream it for free if
you have amazon prime i mean like not
that i'm
endorsing any company but it is you can
watch it for free if you have amazon
prime so worth
checking out um so before we go
um a couple last quick things we said
this before
if you have ever if you if you took our
call to action and jumped on that hi-ho
app we have a video up there right now
where i want people to talk about the
snyder cut and we're going to use it for
something potentially
so if you're on there check it out let
us know what you think about schneider
cut
if you want to bug us in a non email or
phone way
you can find us on social media i think
we'll put those on screen so we can make
sure serbies is there but alec where can
people find you
on social media uh before i do that i
have to
last minute donation from stacy thank
you so much it says i can't keep this
thing live on my phone here's my penance
and my thanks for being amazing as
always so sweet stacy you owe us nothing
and we owe you everything and thank you
so much yes um
i'm on twitter at wisecrack alec also
email us at culturebinge
wisecrack.co you have thoughts questions
whatever i want to get into grad school
we can't yeah um
well did i not say the email before or
were you just reiterating i i can't
wow i'm not doing slaps and chaps i'm
free emails um i'm at michael o'burns
on on all the social medias um find me
if you're cool
miss me if you're a dick um so we will
be back
in two weeks we should be streaming them
i i think culture is really on an
upswing so we're gonna have tons of
stuff to talk about from here to
infinity
vaccination is leading to total chaos in
the world so
lots to talk about um any last thoughts
from you alec
you know it's nice that i feel like
culture was being sucked into a black
hole of donald trump
and even though shrimp guy sucks like
i'm glad that we had that internet saga
i'm not glad that he's shitty but like
these are the stories that can
live and breathe like the suez canal
story
now that things are uh not
i mean there's still a nightmare i don't
know what i'm saying wow that was really
deep we're gonna end on that um serbia
says goodbye as well
um he's been alec i've been michael this
has been culture binge
we'll be back in a couple weeks and we
will see y'all then bye
[Music]
you